- Say, "Trick or treat" to Rose McIver.
(audience cheering)
(haunting music)
(monster laughing)
(woman screaming)
(audience cheering)
Love it!
- Wow
Wednesday.
- Wednesday.
- So you're Wednesday.
So wait, this is, I love this so okay.
From "The Addams Family" so why this one,
why this outfit?
- I've always wanted to
dress up as Wednesday.
I loved "The Addams Family" as a kid.
I feel like,
- Me too.
they just, they were ahead of
their time. They were so cool.
Everybody started dressing
like that about 10 years ago.
Have you noticed?
- Like the goth, goths?
- Yeah, yeah.
The kind of cool, like, edgy hip girls,
like the Indie girls,
- Yeah.
they, they look like Wednesday so-
- It's kind of messed up though
that we liked that movie as a kid.
- [Rose] Yeah.
- (chuckling) It's kind of like,
my kids like it too and
I'm like, "So what part?"
'Cause it's kind of freaky,
(Rose laughing)
for like what-
- Yeah, it's just the hand
by itself,
- It's like Tim Burton
as well, " Nightmare Before Christmas",
I'm like, "So you love this, that's great.
Why?"
(Rose chuckling)
I'm like, it's kind of,
it's kind of freaky.
But What's your favorite Halloween candy,
like trick or treat?
- My favorite Halloween candy
is one that we have in New
Zealand called Pineapple Lumps.
I actually love Pineapple Lumps.
- [Kelly] It's called Lumps?
- Yeah, I know they need
to work on their branding,
I think a little.
- Okay, I was like,
marketing, okay, I wanna try Pine,
I wanted to try your favorite thing.
So I'm going to, oh my God, (laughing)
(Rose gasping)
I hadn't seen you yet.
- [Rose] Look at the service.
- Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my goodness, oh for me?
Ooh! (laughing)
- Oh my God.
I feel like we're on "Indiana Jones" like.
- [Rose] This is great.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Very cool.
- [Kelly] Okay, wait, I'm
gonna put this right here.
You can put yours down if you'd like.
Oh, that was a cooler spot, yeah-
- I've chosen a really
precarious spot.
- I'm gonna try it.
Okay (biting) well.
- What do you think?
- Wait, (candy snapping) okay.
It's a lot tougher
- Yeah,
than I think it should be.
- I think these have been
refrigerated actually (laughing)
- [Kelly] Okay.
That was like, that was
tougher. (chuckling)
- Mm.
Very chewy.
Mm, tastes like home.
- So it's like a chocolate
covered gummy bear kinda?
That's delicious.
- Mm, Thank you.
- So it's like taffy.
Like chocolate covered taffy.
- [Rose] (chewing) Mm hmm.
- Okay.
- I can get through
a few of these.
- I'm leaving that there
or I won't (swallowing)
be able to talk.
(audience chuckling)
So you've been known to
enjoy some costume parties.
I wanted to show this,
'cause this is very creative.
Look at this photo.
So I love how, whoever
designed this costume,
are those wings that you painted as ears?
- [Rose] Thank you, I designed it.
- That's-
- That was all,
that was all me.
- I actually thought
that was really clever.
Like how, what you put
together to make the elephant.
- Well you'd think so.
It's the fairy wings
- Yeah.
and I sprayed them all with spray paint.
But what wasn't clever
was the spray paint.
Because I'd sprayed a stocking with,
full of plastic bags to be my trunk.
- Yeah.
- I thought it was
very imaginative to come up with it.
But unfortunately that
meant I was breathing in
the spray paint fumes all night
and I was a very slow elephant.
- It was clever.
- Thank you.
- Next time,
just make an opening maybe.
- Yeah.
Happy Halloween.
So on "Ghosts", your
character can see ghosts
in your bed and breakfast,
but your husband cannot.
So what's happening this season?
So this season the bed
and breakfast is open,
which is very exciting,
- Yeah.
we've been, we spent a whole
season getting it ready.
Everything that could go wrong did.
But now that it's open,
you'd think it might get
a little bit simpler,
but of course it doesn't.
So, it's now trying to juggle
- No.
the eight ghost roommates that I have,
plus all of the guests
who come in and out.
So we, we have a pretty busy exciting,
some really fun guests
cast this season too.
- This is the show my mother
talks to me most about.
This is why I've seen your show,
because of my, my mother
is like, "Oh my God,
this freaking show."
So does Jason, he likes your version.
There's also one in
the UK I guess as well.
- Oh, yeah?
- Yeah.
No, people are really into it.
- Oh cool.
- It's a great,
it's a great show and great concept,
but, here you are playing a game on set.
I wanted to talk about this.
Look at the end from
your co-star Danielle.
- Four.
- Six.
- (together) Eight.
- 10, 12,
14, 16,
(cameraman laughing)
18, 20, 22,
24, 25, Mancala.
- Yeah, 22.
(Mancala stones clattering)
Congrats.
(cameraman laughing)
I'm over it.
- Her face just.
So, y'all get competitive?
- Yeah, you know, Danielle and I
had been really good friends.
Like we kicked off, we
had a really great sea-
we had a good season together.
And then Mancala came in.
and Mancala, it turns
out, is very competitive.
And it brought out some sides in us
that we had been trying to suppress,
I think (laughing)
- I like that.
Okay, okay, so wait,
when you were on the show "iZombie"
did, was there like a
lot of like fake stuff?
Did you have to do gross
stuff all the time?
Cause there's like blood everywhere
and brains everywhere?
- Yeah, I worked in a morgue.
I was a a medical examiner in that show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so we had a lot of fake body parts.
And what's really scary to me,
is how quickly you get used to them.
And you're not really afraid-
- I was gonna say,
did that gross you out at all?
Oh.
- Initially,
you're sort of like, oh my
goodness that's a fake spleen.
And then by the end
- Yeah.
you're like lobbing it to each
other across the cast tent.
So like-
- (laughing) Catch!
- [Rose] Yeah exactly.
- I freaked out in school
when they make you do
the like frog, like the,
I was like, no.
- No, yeah.
- I didn't, I just said
no, I'll take the zero.
- They didn't do that in New Zealand.
I don't think I'd seen a frog.
- Yeah because you're not
messed up in New Zealand.
Like, Like what the hell?
Why did I need to learn what was the,
- It was obviously-
how is that
helping me right now?
- Something outside-
- That poor frog died
for what?
Like, it was like what?
I didn't really need to
know what was on the inside.
It was very creepy.
I'm very bitter about it.
Still.
- Yeah.